hello everyone sorry for my appearance I
am Yoshiaki Koizumi the producer of
super mario odyssey while I am the
overall producer for the Nintendo switch
hardware I simultaneously have a hand in
the newest Mario game Super Mario
Odyssey this is the first time since
Super Mario 64 and Super Mario Sunshine
that we have created a large Mario
sandbox world like this for you to run
around in the theme of Mario this time
is a journey to an unknown world and
mario has jumped out of the Mushroom
Kingdom to go on an extraordinary
adventure I said unknown but perhaps you
noticed some landscapes that look
familiar from the real world
and at the end of the video perhaps some
of you have noticed some unusual eyes or
something on Mario's Catwoman oh and
right here right there this mysterious
cap in particular offers action that can
only be experienced on Nintendo switch
this cap character plays an important
role in Mario's journey I hope you'll
look forward to it in the 20 years since
we made Super Mario 64 I have been on a
long long journey together with Mario
and we are working on this new journey
called Nintendo switch with the
excitement one feels when visiting
unknown countries for the very first
time I'll be very happy when you can all
join me in departing on this new Mario
journey on Nintendo's switch we plan to
release Super Mario Odyssey in the
holiday season later this year since the
release is still a ways out you won't be
able to play the game today so I hope to
offer you a chance to try it out at
another time so please wait a little
longer thank you very much